hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday December 18th
2023 we are one week away from Jesus's
birthday hey Seuss if you're from a
different part of the world hey Seuss's
birthday Jesus the jar the Son of God
the boss's
son the trippy hippie
the shirtless
wonder the [__] long-haired
Miracle right the fatherless child the
little
bastard his [__] dad's literally
invisible it's his birthday happy
birthday to Jesus what do you say there
hey
Seuss what the [__] are you waiting for
I don't think you're going to come back
we didn't treat you nice the first
time that's probably what's happening
cuz it's going you got to go down there
and H I ain't [__] going back down
there look it was a long time ago things
have progressed have
they all
right you know Dad I mean you [__]
made him why don't you go down there and
deal with it that's kind of [__] up
though that he sent his son down to deal
with us when it was his mistake is that
where that whole thing came about where
uh the sun pays for the sins of the
father is that what it
was I have no
idea um I was actually a religious
historian um in a I can't even you guys
wouldn't believe that for half a second
no I wasn't I was not oh my God can you
imagine having to write a paper on on
[__] Gandhi or whatever whatever
religious person is he religious he was
a dude right he was a guy and he kind of
looked like Ben Ben
Kingsley um and Ben Kingsley played
him and he won an Oscar gandi was Gandhi
and he got killed you know and I think
that that's what's wrong you know Steve
Jobs compared himself to Gandhi or
whatever the hell it is he feels his
company was doing and then he did that
and then he
died curse of Gandhi I I think is that a
real thing um
anyway and then there's also Christmas
shopping did you do all your Christmas
shopping you [__] kids you lazy ass
Christmas shop and you just go on the
internet and give me one of these and
this size what color oh let's just
scroll through is this
[__] model walk you know one picture
wears 48 different [__] colored
shirts and only gets paid
once and then you're all done with your
shopping let me press the gift wrap
button
I still go to the stores and I got all
this [__] you
know I bought all the stuff that I need
to get and then I I got it all uh I got
it all wrapped up I already gift wrapped
the whole thing I just this week I was
like I'm wrapping five gifts a day and
I'm just going to knock this thing out
I'm not going to sit down all at once
I'm not [__] doing that you know
wrapping starts off you you handle it
with care however that thing goes
sure that St Nick soon will be there
right and by like the third package
you're just like [__] this right and you
just you know Wen it up remember my dad
was the worst my mother was the best at
rapping gifts you could always tell the
ones that my dad did you know especially
if it was like a
shirt he would just [__] roll it up
like a newspaper with the with the
the look like a giant crumpled up piece
of uh uh gift wrap and then he just
threw a giant piece of tape over it um
yeah that was not his Forte um anyway so
I hope you guys got all all your
Christmas shopping done I hope you're
going to have a nice one you know a nice
hanuka a nice k quanzi a nice jar
[__] Santa Claus thing or whatever it
is you know and hopefully people will be
nice to one
another maybe in 2024 you know
you could stop hating somebody for dumb
[__] reasons you could maybe shut off
your [__]
TV and that or you know I swear to God
if the next president would just shut
down CNN and Fox News and eliminate the
ability for people to make comments on
the internet like the level of peace
that he would bring to this country and
I am saying he because we all know at
this point it's a man's job all right if
it's a woman's job how come you haven't
gotten it yet you know you ever think
about that let me guess that's our fault
right ladies do you ever take
responsibility for your own actions you
know I don't think you want the job I
really don't because it's been my
experience that if a woman wants
something she gets it all right now that
[__] job has been available since
[__] Ben
Franklin was walking around goose and
chicks and hoop skirts and you have
yet to get that
job um who's run I'm trying to even
think women that have even run for it
Hillary famously did not win the
Democratic
nominee and the Democrats famously gave
it to her anyways typical [__] broad
move she didn't earn it I'll give it to
her
anyway and then what happened and then
[__] uh Joe Biden the second woman to
run for president he didn't win
it right oh Bernie Bernie Sanders got
the [__] Buffalo Sabers 1999 in the
crease treatment [__]
twice happened twice you know I was
thinking about the Buffalo Bills and
they're losing four Super Bowls in a row
the only one you can really break their
balls
about when you think about it is is the
the Redskins loss
all right if you look at the the [__]
New York Giants in 1990 they had like
three Hall of Famers on their
defense they had Lawrence Taylor the
greatest linebacker of all time arguably
the greatest defensive player of all
time all right they had who else they
have they had Harry Carson Leonard
Marshall Chip Banks and guess who guess
who was coming up with the defensive
scheme bill
bellich
all right you're not winning that
one so I you know who gives a [__] they
missed a field goal get get the [__] out
of here was amazing that they were even
in that goddamn game
right and then they went up against the
Dallas Cowboys two years in a row the
Dallas Cowboys the product of the worst
[__] trade in NFL history the Hershel
Walker
trade they got like 10 players and for
some reason in the contract it said if
Jimmy Johnson cut any of the any players
that he cut he got he got the Vikings
number one
picks so they signed the deal and he
immediately cut all 10 of them and then
they got all those picks and then he
just
[__] scored with so many of them they
I mean half that [__] team is in the
Hall of Fame so the only one I'll give
him is they lost to Joe
Gibbs and the Redskins with Mark ripan
and the genius of Joe Gibbs is that he
won three Super Bowls with three
different quarterbacks
right Joe
thyman um Doug Williams and then Mark
ripan you know that's the only one I
give him grief on but the other ones I
mean who the [__] would who who the [__]
was not going to
lose I mean the only people who beat the
giant the patriots who beat b Bill bich
are the Giants right and he was on the
Giants man that was just [__] it was
open and shut
right oh I know Philly fans are probably
upset that they're not getting their not
I always forget that we lost to the
Eagles you know why because we won one
the year before it and the year after it
and it's just like and plus that was the
goofiest Super Bowl I've ever seen in my
life like there wasn't a punt until the
[__] fourth quarter so I don't know
what that was I hated that game um I
hated that game as much as I hated that
Kansas City Chiefs Buffalo Bills game
where there was just no [__] defense
the final score was like
7877 um anyway speaking of
football speaking of football you know
this this this is something that that I
uh you know I'm not the smartest guy
well g bill we never would have noticed
with the first half of this [__]
podcast the first 10% of it I should
say
um you know the Michigan Wolverines they
get suspended for stealing [__] signs
which I get it in baseball not as a base
runner I get why the Astros were in
trouble because you know there's like
five signals in baseball one's a fast
ball two's the slide once you figure
that out you know what the [__] coming
and you add you know the fact that they
they had they were wearing wires they
had a [__] camera they're banging on
trash cans they gave the opposing
pitcher a rofy whatever the [__] they
would do I mean they did everything I
get why they got in trouble well I mean
they weren't really cheating I I believe
it was it's now labeled as the
championship was
complicated you know the NFL I mean NCA
in football they're doing so much to
disguise the signals that yeah how the
[__] would you know you know what's
what's going on you're lucky if you get
one or two of them right in the second
half okay but that's considered cheating
so they [__] punish the uh the
Michigan Wolverines and then meanwhile
this week the Michigan Wolverines are
going up against the Alabama Crimson
Tide and guess what Nick Sabin did guess
what he did he hired Michigan Michigan
parted ways with a coach a linebacker's
coach by the name of George Hilo or as
Kenny feder would say
hello they hired one of their [__]
ex- coaches and for some reason who
coached with them in 2021 and 2022 and
for some reason that isn't illegal
that's totally fine stealing signs
trying to figure out what is that slice
of pie next to to the fs what does that
mean trying to figure that [__] out
that's cheating but you can hire one of
their former coaches and just sit down
with them and be like all right so
what's their playbook when they show us
this look what does that
mean that's not a like let me ask you
guys a question what would you rather be
doing would you rather be have your team
on the [__] Sidelines trying to steal
signs or would you rather hire the other
team one of their [__] ex- coaches
that as of the beginning of this year
was still working or the last season was
working with the [__]
team oh the hypocrisy
I don't know for some reason for that
that's okay Nick Sabin and Alabama
they're not cheating but oh those
Michigan Wolverines Jesus Christ what
are they what are they
doing to the Integrity of the
game
um so obviously Michigan knows it so
then what they can do use to their
advantage is they can just show these
looks and do something completely
different and then you're going to see
Nick looking over at George going what
the [__]
George
I thought you said that that they were
going to they were going to do you know
whatever the [__] they talk about there
um it's so stupid just always know that
whenever whenever in football if you if
you get busted for that
[__] that means you pissed off somebody
at one of the
higher-ups and it was kidding who you
know Jim Harbaugh said something [__]
up to somebody shook somebody's
hands you know squeezed it too tightly
slapped somebody on the back he you know
and they had a [__] readjust their
glasses on their own nose you know he
did something like that that's what I'm
guessing cuz I don't I don't get how you
know that's not there should be like a
time like all right you know you want to
hire somebody else's former [__]
coach you know there's another thing too
it's not like they hired him because
they liked him and they thought he was a
great [__] coach they hired him
because he coached Michigan and now
they're playing Michigan in the playoffs
playoffs that's why he's hiring him he's
hiring the
guy so they can know what Michigan's
doing so he can basically be in their
[__] locker
room which you're not allowed to do
that's cheating but you can hire one of
their [__] coaches just for the sole
purpose of doing that you know what I
mean they're going to stick that guy in
a [__] Airbnb in Alabama and the
second that game's over they're going to
give him some [__] you know saws
barbecue with the mayonnaise base and
tell him to hit the [__] bricks um
but that's totally legit not a
problem
um oh I I got to tell you something man
I I went to the KIA KIA the Kia Forum
home of the great Showtime Lakers in the
80s and what a gorgeous iconic [__]
building that is versus the [__] uh
Bitcoin uh [__] collapse of Society
[__] Staple
Center thing that the Lakers playing now
I mean those [__] archers that place
still to this day has an amazing Vibe
so I went there Saturday
night to go see Queens of the Stone Age
and you know I'm tired the kids are WIP
you know wiped out and that type of [__]
and but as Queens of the Stone Age I
gotta go and I gotta tell you I'm so
[__] happy I went this one of the
best concerts I've ever seen
and I've seen Queens of the Stone Age at
this point I think five times they they
they have never been better they've
never been better
Nia is that you no no hey let me uh let
me finish my podcast I'll be out in a
minute okay
okay all right I'll be out in a
minute um
anyway it's what happens when I do the
podcast in the house so I was like
totally White wiped out and I went down
there to go see him it was [__] un
they sounded better than the [__]
recordings
um I don't even know where to begin how
about we begin at the
beginning they started off right they
come out they they play all this like
old school [__] music and [__] then
the lights go out everyone goes nuts you
see the Shadows going on the [__]
stage oh my God here they come and then
they just open b b b
whole [__] place jumping up and
down going [__] crazy and um I don't
know that was the end of their tour I
hope you guys had a chance to catch him
John Theodore on drums you know I'm a
[__] drum nerd that guy was on a
whole other [__] level and I like I
said I've seen him that guy like four
different times that's my fifth time
seeing him I've never heard him sound
better I never heard his drums sound
better
Josh was killing it uh on guitar and
singing he sounded better than the
[__] record like I don't know how you
do
that
um their bass player Mike's out there
and a [__] wife beat dud they came
like it wasn't like the end of the tour
Dragon ass they came out to chop
everybody's [__] heads off and they
did
it with the other guys Troy on guitar
and Dean on keyboards it was [__]
amazing and this is how good they were
I'm
55 I'm bald and I'm tired and I [__]
stood up for the whole show other than
they had one little thing they had one
little where they played some slow stuff
and they let the older folks sit down
and I knew what they were doing they
were recharging to then just
[__] destroy and then they they you
know cono felt like it was like
literally 11 minutes long I was like why
how how can this be over how can this be
over over this [__] fast it was like
you know it was so [__] awesome it
like flew by then they came out they did
three
songs uh for the
Encore and uh they played
two and Josh was talking to the
crowd and uh then John Theodore's haat
was
going I heard the keyboard start and I'm
like oh [__] they're GNA play songs for
the death and then
[__]
[__] msh pit breaks out and then they
just [__]
unloaded and ended with that at like
Peak [__]
emotions and just set their their [__]
down all the feedback walked off
stage epileptic seizure light show and
then it was just over it was all dark
and you were just like what the [__]
just
happened it was [__] awesome so thank
you to them for ending my year and like
one of the coolest things I've ever been
to I went with
uh I went with Dean Del
re and uh we were [__] just losing
our
minds it was it was it was it was just I
I I don't know I looked at him right
after it right after immediately just
looked right at him and I was like dude
that is
like is is that like one of the best
ones you've ever been been to we also
went Billy row right he was saying the
same thing I was like that's the best
they've ever sounded he goes absolutely
high water mark [__] amazing amazing
goddamn show and then it was just over
and then you just walk out into the
night into the
cold
like what the [__]
it was amazing [__] amazing so
um you know I don't know I'm just you
know that's one of the ones if they're
coming to town you got to go see them
incredible goddamn show so uh I did that
this weekend what else did I oh you know
something I
uh oh I'll wait to tell he talks about
this other thing I I actually had a
daddy daughter day today you know barely
watched any football I'm kind of
thinking like I'm I'm kind of going to
start letting go of sports it's just
like my kids are young once like [__]
this [__] I'm going to go miniature
golfing I'm not going to [__] sit
here and see how my my goddamn bets are
doing right man I'm still you know
betting on football you know what you
know got to have something right so I uh
we went uh miniature
golfing and
uh we had a great time actually played
really good it's my second time playing
the course you know was getting a lot of
pars and I was kind of like trying to
like not go past the
hole and uh I I beat my six-year-old
daughter so I was I was pretty pretty
proud of myself I didn't hold back I
just went out and played you know I beat
her like by 20 strokes and you know it's
the only way she's going to learn it's
old school
parenting um no we had a good time and
then I went over to the batting cages
afterward
right and uh I had my daughter film me
and I have not tried to I'm G to batting
cages and I don't I don't even know when
I think last time I was in my 20s I had
been in there in like [__] 30 years
so I get slow pitch
softball first one comes in swinging a
Miss second one swinging a miss and I'm
just like what the [__] and then I made
contact on every other one of them I
just kept hitting grounders right I
finally got one that looked like it
would be like a fly out to left field
and I had one nice one that would have
been over you know a short stop a white
short stop let's be honest that jump
like me right um Latino dude probably
would have got
it um everything else was just [__]
you know it was all all to [__] short
third and pitches Mound but I still I
still was like you know 55 I'm not bad
but I mean I was up there I was wiggling
the bat and [__] you know I'm thinking
I'm [__] up there looking a little
like you know Gary shefield you know I'm
staying relaxed little Ken griffy Jr
effortless
swing my daughter filmed me I went back
and looked at the footage if there was a
possible way to burn cell phone video
footage I would do it I I can't even
believe what I look
like I had the [__] bat like down
near my waist I didn't I wasn't even
holding it
up it was beyond oldtimers game I was I
looked at that [__] and I was like oh my
God I am
55 like my body didn't even look like it
was communicating with
itself you know look like my brain
brain like like someone like just bought
me and I was like remote control and
they was still trying to figure out like
how to work the mechanics of it it was a
[__]
showell so of course I go home and I'm
going on YouTube and I'm trying to look
up videos on how to improve your goddamn
swing like so the next time I go there
in 30 years in my [__] mid 80s I
don't embarrass myself was still a good
time um until I looked at the footage
like I came out of there I was like ear
to ear grin had on a batting helmet I
felt like a kid again but holy
[__] thank God my wife didn't see that I
mean that's it was like grounds for
divorce you know what I mean that like
like watching me in a batting cage if my
wife came up to me and literally said to
me I am no longer attracted to you
physically I would be like hey you know
ATT tracks I mean I get it so what how
are we going to work this
[Music]
out oh speaking of my wife I learned
something today about women I think for
any of the L for the five ladies that
listen to this [__] podcast so I talk
about [__] football and NCAA football
and batting
cages you need to you need to up your
female demographic
um this what I noticed today Nia had on
her big clothes you know go look you
know I don't know and it was just like
you know I was trying to like you
know you know get something going today
and she just wasn't having it and then I
finally Don wait a minute she she's got
on her big
clothes you know so I finally looked at
her I said I see I I I get it I get it
cuz I asked I said come on over come on
over you know snuggle with me I'm
watching TV come on over she's like no I
got to kind of I just finally took her
in I was like all right I get it I get
it she goes what I go you got on your
big
clothes she goes what she goes you
making fun of what I'm wearing I go no
you got you got on your big clothes you
know you got the oversized t-shirt on
you got your big [__] sweatpants you
got you got on your big clothes big
[__] slippers I get it I get it you
you you want to be left alone
today she goes what are you talking
about go you know you're you're NY big
clo and she just starts laughing she
goes stop calling me that but I know
she's so silly I knew if I just calling
a big close she keep laughing I go you
got on you got on your big clothes like
I I think I figured something out as
much as she was laughing and I was
joking around with
[__] I I think that when it's the
weekend if your girlfriend or wife has
on their big clothes that just kind of
means it's like listen I am not a sexual
entity whatsoever I am here I am
chilling
okay I I I don't even really want you to
talk to me right now all right I got on
my big
clothes I think consciously they're
thinking
I want to be comfortable but
subconsciously they they have on the
antithesis of getting into the club for
free getting a free drink attracting
attention they just like they got on
their big clothes so I'm just going to
let you guys anybody out there in a
relationship all right when when your
wife or your girlfriend has on her big
clothes just just just let her be let
her be and you know and that could
actually work for you later
on cuz you know them I mean they they
put so much
worth on how they look and they'll blame
[__] advertising and men [__] that
that's the like how hot you look for a
woman is like a guy back in the day what
can you bench you know what I mean like
how much [__] can you pick up how much
can you kick the [__] out it was all
about being strong and women it was all
about being pretty it always has been
and there's another thing too it always
will
be all
right you know what's funny is is the no
makeup Trend right but they they always
try to get that thing going and just not
enough women get on
board they're just say I'm not [__]
doing that I'm not going to walk around
and look how I really look that's just
it's just not happening okay I like
getting gift bags all right I'm getting
a bra that's pushing the girls up I'm
putting on my [__] face I'm getting
my hair done I want to you know I want
the free
[__] to
continue I don't
know I know part of that is because of
us but like I think that they they you
know they blaming us way too much for
that there there's a there's a whole
other thing going on there that I'm not
even going to try to figure out cuz I'm
a guy but I will tell you this when your
wife or girlfriend has on her big
clothes it's just like all right that's
it I see it I see what's going on
here you know
I I'm going I'm going to I'm I I
received that is that what you're
supposed to say now I hear what you're
saying with your clothes and I will [__]
off I will stay on my side of the couch
I I'll leave the [__] room you
know she was one more big article of
clothing away from me just getting up
and just maybe just going for a drive
it's just like she really needs to be
alone all right so keep an eye out for
that the big clothes the big cloth
there's a lot of things that are being
said you know don't even let it be no no
the 90s style is coming back by the way
everybody's like loving the 90s like it
was the worst [__] decade ever for
fashion all of those oversized [__]
clothes everybody looked was walking
around looking like they just dropped 80
lbs you know and they had a bunch of
loose skin under their shirt it was
[__] horrible the chicks walking
around with those big stupid boxy jeans
they had on their big clothes they in
their big clothes and they grew out
their bushes and that's what really
happened in the the '90s and nobody
wants to talk about it it's big cover up
you know and that's why Henry Kissinger
finally died cuz they were trying to
distract from that story it's [__]
that's all true you can look it up
um anyway uh I've still been working out
I've been doing good I've been staying
away from the goddamn
sweets and
uh I flew a couple times this week I
finally got you know been pitching the
idea for the next movie pitches have
been going great some people are
interested we'll see what the [__]
happens think I got another great idea
for a movie we'll see we'll see and
uh so the other day I had to you know I
had to bring my uh my little two-seater
out to get you know every 50 hours they
change the oil they go over the whole
[__] thing make sure everything's
right so I had to go fly it and uh drop
it off somewhere man and and it was just
like it was a [__]
gorgeous gorgeous just goddamn day just
a beautiful day like this time of year
once the Santa Ana winds [__] die
down and I don't know what I don't know
why but the skies are ridiculously clear
I always say this is the time of year
when people go up in helicopters and
they take pictures of downtown LA for
the postcards you know for the tourism
does anybody buy postcards anymore at
least back in the day and you see
downtown LA and behind it is like snow
cap mountains and I would always see
pictures of that and I would just be
like when the is that
like was that taken from the stealth
bomber where you can see like [__]
from downtown LA to like Utah like what
what are those snow cap mountains that
mount
baly um it's this time of year so I did
one of my favorite transitions of any
airspace is the uh the seula boulevard
over LAX 2500 ft and you just get to see
you
know what a [__] Bravo airspace
airport looks like for real Pilots
commercial airline pilots not jerk offs
like me and uh it's amazing at 2 200 ft
you know looking down it's funny is like
the airport itself where all the people
are you can't believe how small it looks
it's like how the [__] are all those
people in that little ass thing compared
to like the runways and all of this [__]
where the Jets are like the airport
where all the people go looks like it
takes up 10% of the land it's really
incredible but it's funny you go over
that southbound transition then you
immediately have to get on with
Hawthorne airport and then you get on
with
Torrance and then you can fly down and
go around the palace ver Peninsula and
you come out the other side you're down
near Long Beach you fly over the Queen
Mary you get back on with torren you fly
over the Queen Mary you make your radio
call The Long Beach it's just [__]
it's so cool so goddamn cool cool um
anyway so I kind of have a little bit of
time off right now so uh I'm going to be
doing that just [__] zipping around
in this beautiful goddamn weather all
right I think I I covered everything I
wanted to talk about um all right let's
do some advertising reads here for the
week um oh by the way and what the [__]
happened to the Cowboys this week they
didn't even show
up goddamn Buffalo Bills did good for
them and look at the Buffalo Bills
everybody writing them off including me
these
[__] could win the goddamn
division now Nick Crow with the with the
with the Miami Dolphins down there he
needs to win I guess one more [__]
game in the next two weeks but the next
two weeks the bills ain't playing [__]
and the Dolphins had the Eagles and
somebody else somebody else
tough and [__] uh the bills have like
the Chargers who Jesus Christ they quit
on their coach Thursday night they just
[__] quit I know Herbert's out or
whatever and but
you what a way to [__] send your
coach out man they didn't even show up
for that [__] Raiders game and I
thought the Cowboys I don't know what
happened today is that all you have to
do is just sort of Smash him in the
mouth and then they get all like well I
thought you know I knew we were playing
tackle I didn't think it was like tackle
tackle like they kind of got
uh they kind of look like little boys up
there in
Buffalo here's something I didn't know
there's another Josh Allen in the league
and he plays for the Jaguars how come I
only know this is this is like you know
during cancel culture why do we only
know about the white Josh
Allen the other one plays on uh not
white Josh Allen plays on the
Jacksonville Jaguars and I got the
[__] Ravens and this guy is a goddamn
problem I learned about him Collinsworth
going if he's going the Jags are going
if he's not going they have a bad game
well guess what he was going when
I just one of those weird games I
watched a couple of when I came home
after the the miniature golf and
embarrassing myself humiliating myself
in the batting
cages um I still got the bat around
though I'll tell you this man you come
in in my [__] house and I got a bat
you know I I got a [__] 30% chance of
hitting your melon you know although
that was coming right down the pike but
if you saw me coming you put some action
starts becoming like a [__] Tim
Wakefield you know knuckle ball rest his
soul then then then I'm going to have a
problem that's how slow my bat speed was
never impressive right that's what she
said um but my uh I stand by that's what
she said I [__] love those jokes I
think they're funny and if people don't
find them funny it annoys them and then
there's a whole other Neville NE neev
another level of
Comedy I'd have to swing Center Mass
you know like when when you go to shoot
you know what I mean all these [__]
jerk offs they go down to the gun range
they're always pointing at the [__]
they're trying to blow somebody's brains
out you know which they do on a
cardboard cut out but you're not hitting
the [__]
head you're not hitting the [__] head
when it's showtime all right you're
you're going to you're going to get
somebody in the
ribs you're going to get the pancreas
you know what I mean you you might hit
them in the solar plexus but you are not
hitting somebody in the [__] head
unless they're just right
there and you're going hold
still hold still you know what I
mean hold still do you remember do
anybody old like me do you remember
hearing that when you were a kid hold
still you remember what that meant that
meant uh I am not trained medically but
we don't have the money to go to the
hospital so we're going to [__] do
this at home hold still I said hold
still it
[Music]
hurts that in my house that was anything
from getting a tooth pull to [__]
getting
stitches
um anyway uh yeah my dad used to stitch
us up right at the [__]
house we were always getting stitches
and he got sick of going you know he was
a dentist back in the day and uh he
would just Stitch you up like a [__]
hockey
game and he' make you know one of your
siblings would be the assistant and
that's just basically how it went down
it's very
convenient um all right let's do the
uh let's do some reads here for the week
oh look who it is everybody it's old
zip
c z recruit everybody talk about that
one person on your holiday list who's
really hard to find the perfect gift
for you know what my
manager my manager is really different
difficult you know he's a beautiful
human
being and uh I think he kind of has
everything that he wants so I'm trying
to think of what to get the guy and I I
don't I don't know what to get him you
know box of cigars is usually a good
thing but like I don't know you got to
watch out you know you never know how
somebody's like spouse is with having
like cigars in the [__] house or
whatever um anyway what is this have to
do with hiring somebody at work I I I
don't understand this line of
questioning anyway this person says
right now whoever wrote this we're
getting it to you what what if you're a
business owner you need to okay but if
you're a business owner wait talk about
one person on your holiday list who's
really hard to find the perfect gift
for oh then they oh some of the copy not
here I don't know what the [__] this is
I'm just going to read it but if you're
a business owner and you want to grow
your team your perfect gift is simple
you want a smart hiring solution so look
no further than
zip and right now we're gifting it to
you for free it's ziprecruiter.com
how is
Zip Zip it's the devil Read a gift to
those who are hiring well zip uses smart
matching technology to identify the most
quality ified people for a wide range of
roles all right you're making the league
minimum you spike going zip recruiter
lets top candidates know when they're a
great match for your job to encourage
them to apply and the bow on
top oh they're using AE a present
reference here the and the bow on top if
you see a candidate who's a great match
for your job
zip makes it easy to send send them a
personal invite so they're more likely
to apply so getting your hiring wrapped
up so get your hiring wrapped up quickly
with
zip four to five employees who employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire why
do I feel like I I'm lost half of that
go to ziprecruiter.com I believe is what
that is all right look who it is
everybody oh look cool it is it's all
Indo
Cheeto you know nothing feels quite like
giving the perfect
gift oh I mean come on I mean that's a
good feeling but there there's better
feelings right taking a [__] um and no
gift fits more perfectly than an
indochino
suit uh they're made to measure and
totally customizable with Endless
Options do you want Tails do you want
one tail you want a mock turtleneck
choose your own own cut fabric lining
and more to create the suit of your
dreams at a surprisingly affordable
price give an indochino gift card for
that perfect fit uh gift or use the code
Burr at indochino.com to get 10% off any
purchase of $3.99 or more I want to get
one of these suits and go on tour with
it because if I go out and go buy some
high-end [__] suit high-end clothes
suck you wear them like three times and
like oh I don't feel right and they're
all pillowy or whatever the [__]
whatever that thing is where you got the
little balls of fabric you fold them up
like twice and they just quit like the
Dallas Cowboys today in Buffalo set up
your me measurement profile in less than
10 minutes measure yourself from the
comfort of your own home or make an
appointment at one of their showrooms
with new colors fabrics and outer wear
Styles it's easy to create your next
look choose the customizations you want
I'm going to buy one of the these things
and just tell my wife I bought a Tom
Ford suit and I guarantee you she's not
going to be able to tell from buttons
and vents to pockets and
lapels sounded like one of those
Christmas Rhymes uh select your Styles
and they'll build it every suit is made
to your exact measurements and every and
you can customize every detail they also
offer Blazers pants skirts outerwear and
more give a perfect gift with indochino
go to go to indochino
and use the code bird to get 10% off any
purchase a 3.99 or more that's 10% off
at
IND
c.com with code
bur all right I guess that's it I guess
that's it for the reads all right now
we're into the we're into the we're into
the [__] money round here and this is
when for some
reason you guys like to ask me
advice or give me [__] I don't know what
it is it says Bill Good emails the eff
for Frank email came from someone who
didn't know it ended and heard on the
throwback that you were that you were
ending it I included the email to throw
the show back
in The Ether Before Christmas oh okay
yeah let's let's start watching after
some family again all right F is for
Frank this person right okay for those
of you you know new to my podcast I did
a uh an animated show with the great
Mike Price
from The Simpsons the
co-creator we did five seasons on
Netflix we were one of the first hits on
Netflix in North America right after um
House of
Cards we got there second like that
second guy that stepped on the moon
um and the show is over I guess this
person didn't realize it this is like
well remember those stories where they
was like Japanese
soldiers that for decades were still
hiding on Islands thinking the war was
still going I mean the level of
dedication um you should look that up
man that's [__] wild that's a wild
thing there okay this person says F is
for Frank okay this can't be true my
husband just told me that you announced
on your podcast you're done I'm so sad
you should really
reconsider what when the [__] did I say
I'm
done uh email came from someone who
didn't know it ended and heard on a
throwback
oh oh they heard on one of the Throwback
Thursdays that I was ending it well I
didn't end it Netflix ended it um
so I'm well I'm very flattered that
you're sad um I will say this when
Netflix decided to end it we still had a
lot more in the
tank um so it it it never dipped and I
thought it ended on a high point and I
love the ending of the show and the
little nod that we do to little Bill's
future um so check it out if you
can we had an all
starcast of uh voiceover
actors um a couple of whom went on to
win like
Oscars you know while we were doing the
show like we got them before they were
Oscar
winners
um like Sam
Rockwell
uh Laura D I don't know I'm going my
[__] head my head's gonna [__] we
had David Kenner Debbie Derry
Barry uh Mo Collins that was that was so
much fun you know what's the most fun
about doing that
show um was the table reads that was the
worst thing with Co was we couldn't have
them anymore our [__] t table reads
were
amazing um and all the great writers you
know David Richardson rest his
soul um ma Wilmore rest his soul and we
just used to have so much fun and just
watching the actors voiceover actors
like cracking up trying to do their
lines and stuff Haley Reinhardt oh my
god
um Justin
long I remember being in the booth with
that guy him and Sam Rockwell if I got
in the booth with those guys like I I
couldn't look at him because I was going
to start laugh we had Vince vaugh come
on one season and he's actually the
reason why we sold the damn show cuz he
would go he went in when I was pitching
it around town and you know people
barely knew who I was and I was sitting
there with this [__] aist movie star
so uh tip of the cap to him too um
anyway I'm glad you're enjoying it
people uh yeah why don't you go back and
uh check it
out check check it out man all right
better drum
riff um old Billy Ginger balls which
drum riff intro from Phil Rudd gets the
red pubes on your cornhole to tingle
more Jesus buddy come out of the closet
stop throwing all your gay stuff at me I
get it you find me attractive all right
I'm sure there's a redheaded gay guy oh
the redhead
gay what sketch [__] show is that D
and the redhead gay the state um walk
all over you intro or Shoot to Thrill
intro oh which one do I like
better
um well Shoot to Thrill it's the
breakdown towards the
end and that's just all of them and the
magic of them and their ability to one
at a
time all come back in and each person as
they come in just build more and more
power and tension until they just just
Phil rud finally hits a [__] crash
symbol and the whole place goes nuts so
I would say the better intro though is
walk all over
you um which
interestingly enough I was trying to
play to the other day and that is not an
easy song it's not an easy song it's
uptempo your [__] arm gets
tired uh mine does anyways trying to
play those eighth notes at that
Tempo and then all of a sudden it goes
into like a halftime feel those those
fills that he does in the beginning the
first one starts on the and of one get
get Blom get Blom right then the second
one I think starts on the end of four g
g g g
g yeah basically um any Phil rut thing I
will tell
you um what's really been giving
me the chills
going back and listening to Phil rud as
I always
do um I I always learned something else
something that I heard wrong or I
understand
something that he's doing
better and uh it's what's next to the
moon on the power rage
album and uh you know he's playing this
this florom and ratom groove during the
verse for the first first two verses but
on the uh the third
verse when they come out and Bon like uh
long I'm looking for a fingerprint
trying to find a mystery clue and he's
[__] on the hat then and it's just Bo
bat Bo bat Bo bat just the way he's
driving it it makes the [__] hair on
my arm stand up it's amazing it's
[__] amazing and that's what I love
about I love about all the
drum parts of that
song is like when he's playing on the
toms it's like it's totally driving the
song it's totally
happening and why did he go to the high
hat there and why is it so
cool and it just adds a whole other
color to it or whatever the [__] you're
supposed to say musically and it just
the song Just
sores in the end until they get It's
Your Love that I want and then they just
r out on that
um yeah mean give me a break dude you're
going to [__] you're going to bring
up [__] Phil rut I can talk about
that forever for [__] ever I mean
Phil Rudd is the drummer of my favorite
[__] band of all time he plays my
favorite instrument of all time and the
guy flies helicopters you
know and he
battles you
know [__] alcohol and drugs and [__]
and I I I just [__] I just on all levels
I relate to that guy
um which by the way I had uh a cup of
coffee yesterday and I had a cup of
coffee today and I got to tell you I
don't [__] like it anymore I don't
know what happened I went to my favorite
[__] place and I had I don't like it
I'm just like yeah I don't know I think
I this is the one thing that I can out
of all the [__] addictions that I've
had and and that I've tried to get away
from this is the only one I've ever come
back to and I'm like I I I'm not into
this anymore and I'm thinking like I
just must have got a bad cup I was so
[__] into it just I don't know I
think I just ODed like you ever do that
like I remember when I was living in New
York you know they was like the only
chain [__] restaurants they had like
they had like McDonald's and just [__]
food like that right and then it was all
like these mom and pop places so you
lived in your neighborhood and these
[__] restaurants when you when you
ordered takeout they would only deliver
in a so many block radius so after you
lived in your neighborhood for a couple
of
years you're like praying to God
something new would open up right so I
remember at one point uh Chipotle opened
up when it first opened up and everybody
thought it was healthy and they didn't
realize that it was run owned by
McDonald's right I went down there like
every [__] day for like I think like
6 days in a row and I got a burrito bowl
with their [__] avocado guacamole
[__] right and I don't know what
happened on that sixth day I've never
eaten there again just like I I can't
like I look at the place and I just want
to throw up every time I drive by it's
like I can't [__] do it right um I
think I did that with coffee I just had
it like every [__] day and my body's
like all
right
enough um
okay so anyway U that was the old school
way they used to they used to try to
make that they you caught your kids
smoking you'd go out and you make them
smoke a whole pack of cigarettes U and
you get all sick and throw up that was
like the way to
the you know Jesus good thing they
didn't catch him doing coke all right
you can [__] do this whole eightball
like some person the first time they do
Coke has money for an eightball all
right I'm an idiot all right playing
stupid with health and Southwest
Airlines
um by the way if I see one more [__]
idiot you play stupid games Win stupid
prizes that [__] thing and then what
was the other one oh any animal video
where an an where a predator is killing
prey somebody always has to write I know
this is difficult but this is
nature like when the [__] did I see did
I say that I needed you to hold my hand
through this [__] video you're
sitting at home in your [__] pajamas
too stop acting like you're out in the
wild wearing a loin cloth and some
[__] knife you made out of a [__]
bamboo tree all right playing stupid
with health in Southwest Airlines oh
yeah Southwest Airlines said I guess
said if you're [__] overweight you
don't have to pay for the seat next to
you and you can board
first you know there's no way
they're having these Chow hounds getting
on before disabled people of the troops
there's no [__] an active [__] you're
in the Marine Stand
Down stand down sge all
right we got somebody over here that
likes a [__] uh what are those a
blizzard at Wendy's I like my Patty
square and I like my [__] shakes to
sound like the weather um hey Bill I'm
one of those people who is enraged by
fat Fox lecturing me about health over
the last few years yeah that was one I
didn't take the bait on it's just I look
at them they are [__] addicts and
they need to they need to break the
sugar salt thing and they need to read
up on nutrition and they got to get
control of their lives or they're going
to [__] die um I didn't get enraged
by them because I've also battled with
like uh sugar addiction which for me I
just [__] for me did I really just
say that I just [__] said I don't eat
dessert I like saying that you know to I
like saying that to another guy too like
I was at a Christmas party somebody you
to get in on this cheesecake and I just
go I don't eat dessert you know what I
mean and I see that look in their face
they're like is this guy like
questioning my manhood here and it's
like I absolutely
am you want to cure people of [__]
like all men of [__] eating sugar
like it's like if you if you go into
like the coffee shop and you order
something sweet you should be you have
to eat it there in P public and you have
to put on one of those old school party
hats you know with the thin [__]
rubber band and then it's like a little
[__] triangle on top of your head you
should have to [__] sit
there and eat it as everybody just looks
at you shaming you
um anyway uh so I'm one of those people
who actually was enraged by fat [__]
lecturing me about health over the last
few years I've spent my whole life not
being an [__] when it comes to food
if you're unhealthy or unhappy with your
life I don't want to hear your
views uh on literally anything I have no
sympathy for fat people who haven't
undergone any
trauma uh I have fat family members so I
know firsthand that most have no excuse
I hate waking up early to work out but I
do it three times a week it's no easier
for me than it is for anyone else Amen
to
that [__] Amen to that yeah yeah it
isn't it [__]
sucks um until you get there and you get
a couple of reps in especially if you're
doing upper body you know what I mean
then you start lying to yourself I'm a
[__] beast right and then you film
yourself in a batting cage and you want
to crawl under a rock um it's no easier
for me than it is for anyone else and
when people act like it is it's an
excuse for their own laziness 100% 100%
I mean you're explaining a lot of female
Behavior here they get away one of the
reasons why so there's so many fat
[__] broads out there is not be look
you had a couple of kids I'll give you a
pass but like the amount of them that
are just out there just [__] out
there like they're getting ready to go
to slaughter it's because like no one
can can call him fat anymore you know
what I mean you got to say oh you're
beautiful oh your plus side it's like no
man like what did you look like five
years ago yeah you [__] lay off the
donuts sweetheart Jesus Christ
you [__] [__]
sugar uh Southwest Airlines has decided
to give an extra seat to fatties for
free if they need it I don't have a
problem with that I don't want to sit
next to one right next to
him right
next uh they dangled donuts and fast
food in front of people's faces to get
the
job what that's my thing you know for
fatties if if they get an extra [__]
seat that's another thing too like the
message that they're
sending you get status for being fat so
if you actually start eating salad
you're like I can't do this do it for
your family well I fly every weekend I
don't want to lose my extra seat uh
MSNBC tried to tie home workouts to far
right white
supremacy that all tracks I don't
understand why you guys watch those
[__] shows those channels I
mean
MSNBC CNN and Fox News you might as well
be watching The Real
Housewives uh here's a conspiracy theory
for you anyone defending any of these
things hates
themselves and anyone saying these
things aren't a big deal are idiots too
uh they're the same ones worried about
rhetoric in every other area but when
kids are getting fatty liver disease at
eight years old we have to worry about
how other people's feelings will be
affected yeah it does it makes about as
much sense as like getting you know
suspended for stealing signs but the
other team can hire your [__] coach
you just fired eight months ago it's
[__]
um yeah no that that somewhere
like
liberals scared the [__] out of
corporate lawyers with cancelling and
and um they always get nervous when
there's any sort of like
uh what's the [__] word
discrimination any sort of disc now race
I understand but that the fact that like
fat people are under the same [__]
umbrella is uh racial discrimination
which by the way another embarrassing
moment in Massachusetts history I guess
they have some sort of Asian mayor or
something out there or whatever and she
had a Christmas party and it went out
that it was whites own not no no not
whites only it was no white people
allowed
she claimed it was a
typo and uh whatever whatever I I don't
know what the [__] happened right but
all I know watching like white people in
Massachusetts or whatever are online
complaining about that like yes see when
they do it it's not considered [__]
racist it's like people non-white people
were not allowed to go after their
dreams and and achieve their potential
or feel [__] safe for 200 years you
can't go to one [__] Christmas party
and you're you're doing an equivalency
thing there it's just it's the [__]
it's the worst but it is how human
beings are it is all and we don't give a
[__] about anything until it affects us
and I mean everybody I mean [__]
everybody I'm not just saying white
people like that every that is human
[__] Behavior you know why that's
[__] up because it affects me um case
of that's why empathy is the I feel one
of the hardest of human emotions to get
outside of your own [__] [__] and
actually give a [__] about something
that's affecting somebody else that
doesn't have any effect on your life you
know what I
mean as I'm [__] trashing fat people
um did I trash I think I did but they're
not doing those
people
um I don't know I I don't give have an
extra seat I don't give a [__] they
should have an extra seat they're as big
as two seats they shouldn't just have
one and spill into your seat so I don't
have a [__] problem with that all
right but I would say uh you know
calling him
healthy you know I don't know somebody
actually said wait a minute somebody
sent me a text message today with a
picture um it was on the cover of
Cosmopolitan they had this Spanish
actress on there and she's definitely
plus-size and Cosmo wrote this is
healthy
okay uh um says Spanish
actress it's z z it's Z Castro who
fought against fat phobia dies aged
46 and uh look man she shouldn't like
not be able to get a job I understand
all of that type of stuff and they
shouldn't be shamed and all of that [__]
I
100% get that but like to tell them that
they're healthy and that this is healthy
that's a very Reckless
[__]
I mean I you know it would be great if
like alcoholics could piggy back behind
that and you just got somebody faed down
in a bar at like 2: in the afternoon on
a Wednesday and you just write this is
healthy oh wait a minute didn't I you I
did a bit about that didn't I [__]
plagiarizing myself here all right case
oh I here the dumbest [__] I think I've
ever
said my daughter goes dad dad there's a
there's a there's a flying you know in
here right get the fly swatter so I
thought it was a big house [__] close the
bathroom door so it's you know it's
locked in there now now you can't sleep
right so she leaves and I go in there
and it's a [__] mosquito and I'm
swinging at this thing cuz it won't land
anywhere and I couldn't hit it and I
said out loud to nobody about a mosquito
I said this [__] fly isn't human cuz
I couldn't hit
it and then it was one of those things
where you just say something really dumb
like that out loud and then I was just
kind of I had to stop swinging the fly
water and be like well yeah it isn't
human bill it's a it's a [__] insect
okay let's just say you didn't know what
humans look like you you you at least
knew they couldn't fly right all right
case of the
Monday and Gary
Indiana hey Billy burrito balls I liked
your rant last Monday about people
bitching for decades about how they
loathe Mondays I believe it was the Dal
Lama who once said Mondays are fine it's
your life that
sucks Jesus do you have a couple of Pops
I like that edgy edgy doy Lama was that
when he was a young angry man realizing
that he's to spend his whole life
[__] walking around in his big
clothes uh that aside I was quite
surprised to see Gary Indiana in your
2024 tour dates you're like the third
person that's going what the [__] are
you going to Gary Indiana for why
wouldn't I go to Gary
Indiana why wouldn't I anyway I had no
idea they had a venue capable of hosting
a big National headliner such as
yourself oh keep the compliments com
coming I'm too big for Gary
Indiana wasn't it little Ronnie Howard
who's saying Gary Indiana Gary Indiana
Gary that's the town I [__] knew me
when from the music man all
right anyway uh I drove through there
last year and had never been more
uncomfortable and depressed in a city
just seconds After exiting the
interstate it seemed like every other
building had collapsed had a collapse
roof and looked as though a catastrophic
storm that should have made national
news had torn through the town yeah
those was a I know and these politicians
don't do a [__] thing about it all
they do is just they serve their [__]
corporations and their
International interests they're all done
with us here if you haven't noticed
corporations are all done with us here
all they want is whatever money that we
have left uh old abandoned schools
churches theaters and so on all great
for photo ops none of which I was
comfortable to get out of my car
for um it's how I imagined what it must
have been like to be in New Orleans
shortly after Katrina but nope this has
merely been it was what Detroit still
looks like in a lot of places but thank
God Detroit is coming back Cleveland
looked like that for a while you know
they're all coming back Buffalo's come
you know come back you know they all
that whole Rust
Belt thing you know it comes back and
technology and then they build these big
glass towers for high-end apartment
rentals and no one can afford
it um but nope this has merely been a
trait of a city in shamas and
deterioration for decades its population
has shrunk by 33% since 200000 and
currently has a population of around
68,000 when its peak was 178,000 in 1960
maybe you're already know all of this
but it's it is all due to the decline of
the steel industry and layoffs of
workers after facing competition
overseas now let's I like how that's
just facing competition overseas no what
happened was was the people running the
steel companies did not want to pay
people a a you know a living wage they
wanted to take advantage of sweat shop
labor they wanted to go back to the
Industrial Revolution when they had
children working in factories and that's
what the [__] they've done and they took
away American jobs and then they and
then they exploit people from other
[__] countries children and women and
all of that stuff and they just do it
all around the [__]
world and they don't get you know they
don't get taken to task for that and we
sit around talking about hey can you
believe fat people are getting two seats
on South Southwest Airlines that's the
[__] that they talk about and then MSNBC
does all these misdirections going like
well you know this [__] thing was
actually from White supremist and blah
blah blah and just all the the Scuttle
butt those three [__] networks I'm
telling you all it's like you're
listening to a bunch of old ladies in a
[__] coffee shop they don't know what
the [__] going on um this person says
I know you are likely not going to be
hanging out in the streets while you're
there but thought you might be
interested in a few videos I found after
my trip and quite frankly I probably
wouldn't have felt as
unsafe had I watched these beforehand
kind of hard to get mugged or murder in
a borderline ghost town as my experience
there replayed in my head I kind of got
obsessed with learning everything I
could and found the following links to
be highly
informative
um eat a freckled [__] and all the best
well Jesus Christ all right let me see
what we got here
uh